let's jump into the first story the only
story that matters Mark Zuckerberg and
Elon Musk Italian government offer fight
like true Gladiators at the Coliseum the
ministry of culture's office is in a
statement saying there have been no okay
so they're already writing on our parade
this because this this is the update
literally as of right now there has been
no formal contact from the ministry nor
any written document even if the news
appears uh tasty it is unfounded the
initial report was that an official from
the government of Italy contacted
Zuckerberg about staging a UFC fight
against Elon at the most legendary
Battleground in the world you know why I
think it's more likely they did make the
offer I think they're panicking and
they're saying no no we never we never
made this up no I think someone probably
did I think someone was like a
preliminary look if someone in Italy was
going to entertain the possibility the
first thing you got to do is figure out
if Elon and Zuckerberg would do it you
can't go to the government say hey let's
prepare the Coliseum for a UFC fight
we'll book them later no no the first
thing we'll do is they'll go to Mark
Zuckerberg and say hey how would you
feel about fighting at the Coliseum
zuckerbergtel somebody this story goes
viral and it was preliminary in the
sense that you need to know for sure
they want to do it before you make any
moves to prepare for it but uh what do
you think Alex you don't think they
would just fake it for the publicity and
just say that that I mean it's a
possibility I just I don't believe
anything that I read in the news so I
think that they could just be you think
he's just lying about it I mean yeah
they're just trying to get some cloud or
I just want to believe it's true tweeted
it I know I want to believe it she
tweeted it Elon said there's a high
possibility the fight happens at the
Coliseum oh that's where it should
happen and as he says the most
entertaining outcome is the most likely
I highly agree that would be the most
entertaining outcome do you think elon's
just manifesting though like no one from
Italy was I don't think he needs to
manifest
we got a tweet right here he said some
chance fight happens in Coliseum I told
you so we need to work on my endurance
it's a non-zero chance he said he needs
to work on his endurance yeah you know
Lex Friedman sparred with both these
guys Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg and
at the end of it all he said I love
these guys I had so much fun I want them
to to be sparring partners I don't want
them to actually fight because you know
you break Elon musk's brain that's a big
problem for a lot of people same with
Zuck so I kind of with Mark I I don't
even think it has to be like wet blanket
like womp it's it could be really great
to see Elon and Mark Spar and to see
them become friends and and work
together for the future I would I would
agree I don't think elon's Mom is too
happy either if you've seen her tweets
do you think Elon would consider a
performance-enhancing neural link to
help him in the fight he hooked himself
up to a computer to give him an
advantage his neural Net versus
Zuckerberg's meta net yeah I mean they
can read each other somehow they both
need to hook up to a computer and fight
in the metaverse and then nobody gets
hurt if you if you were gonna do a
boxing match and you can somehow have
like an augmented chip or system so that
you could read your opponent's algorithm
like you could see their muscle you
could see what part of their muscles
were getting hot how fast parts of their
body were moving would you augment well
yeah I mean I think the future you know
we joke about this a lot in but I've
really I'm a conspiracy theorist and
with tin foil hat wearing but I do
believe that that is the future that
they're going to tell people to plug
into a computer some sort of Vanilla Sky
fake world you're going to live in some
sort of pod but on Earth they're gonna
say you only live till 70 years but in
this pod you're going to live for a
thousand years because more than that or
more than that no no but I mean more
than just being Immortal they're gonna
say in the Pod you can fly yeah oh yeah
in the quarterback of the Dallas Cowboys
what was that you identify as a carrot
in the Pod you can be a carrot exactly
right and the Pod you are a carrot
carrot World Imagine somebody being like
I just feel like I was born in the wrong
body I'm a carrot and then they plug you
in and you go into a fake world where
every other person has an AI generated
NPC and their carrots and you live in a
world where everyone's carrot
that'd be better than what's happening
right now to be honest
that's why they're making the world so
bad metaverse carrot they want you to
have such a terrible life you know just
be totally base basically destitute
can't make any money so that your only
option is that you live in this computer
where you're a millionaire it's a
long-term marketing yes I mean is is
cipher wrong when he's eating the steak
and he's like I don't care that's the
best part of the movie really yeah think
about it because like do you really want
to go back to the Matrix I probably
would I mean if you're on a ship with a
bunch of dudes like pooping you know in
a bucket in a bucket you know that movie
is terrible or you can go to the fake
metaverse where you can just eat steak
and be but once you know dude once you
know it's like
knowing that your body is in some metal
tank
you know in a pod being pumped full of
bugs no steak whatever taste is good
you'd be like constantly like uh you
know what I mean well I don't know but
my dreams feel real sometimes you've had
a dream that felt real
well I'm just saying in the in the
metaverse or whatever when you're
plugged in your dreams could feel like
it's real I mean I've had sex in a dream
and it felt real I mean I've I mean I've
eaten in a dream it seemed like I was
eating food every time I tried punching
in a dream my hands would move real slow
running away you're like you're worse
reading but you know what I still have
do you guys have stress dreams I have a
dream and it's recurring I don't have it
as much anymore where I wake up in the
middle of the night and it's a friend
calling me and he's like why aren't you
at the exam right now and I get I have
that I have that regularly like I don't
I don't have that because regular dreams
about missing exams no it was like I
always had this dream when I was in
college that I had signed up for a class
and then somehow forgotten about it and
on the last day of semester you remember
you have to go take a final yeah or it's
like it's definitely feels like
something you have forgotten that sense
is always it'll be like a football game
like I'll be in high school and be like
oh I got a football game tonight and I
can't get there it's weird yeah I have
dreams like that but it's more like I
missed the show yeah seriously yeah
that's exactly I'll have a dream where
it's like where where our car broke down
in DC and it's like we're not gonna make
get back in time what do we do and I'm
like wow I'm gonna miss it mine where
I'd be uh have a play that night and I
didn't know my lines I forgot to
memorize my lines but I'm all going on
stage in the dream and it's like yeah I
have this recurring nightmare where Alex
Stein is boxing a guy and that's
terrifying that's a scary dream yeah me
but uh yeah you're gonna be is that
what's going on what's going on you're
like unboxing yes guys everybody July
22nd Misfits 008 you're looking at the
newest Logan Paul wannabe Prime Time
Alex sign I'm going head-to-head against
Modine in a no holds bar well there are
rules so it's there are whatever
some bars there are rules unboxing
snow head gear and uh it's three two
minute rounds in Modine you better watch
out dog because I'm gonna bring the
Thunder and the lightning I was noticing
you're looking a little thin I am thank
you Tim Tim's been very nice to me and
uh two that girl last week There's a I'm
telling you I've never seen more sushi
in my life I thought I was in Japan when
I walked in you have a refrigerator full
of why do you have so much Sushi it's
Friday I know but that you got a lot I
mean there's a lot there's a platter
people work here we get two trays for
like 30 people normally like the scraps
we throw to the chickens but the
chickens are in an emergency holding
facility to do the air quality which is
improved so nothing can come home yeah
the air quality is totally safe now it
rained I'm very happy this morning I was
inhaling that oxygen stuff really works
yeah I got a question about about
everybody getting put in pods you guys
were talking about that earlier so you
said they think like they want people in
pods just because like they want you to
at least I've talked about this they
want they want to like control people
and make sure they don't go crazy put
them in the Pod do you think that they
people really believe that if we were
happy and we started pairing up and
having families and like communities
that that would actually be a bad thing
is there like a thought that that would
be bad somehow yes because they hate you
like what is it they hate what do you
think they hate you are the carbon they
are trying to reduce you're a peasant
well if they want to eradicate if you're
trying like imagine this imagine you
have roommates who keep pooping on the
floor you would like to not have those
roommates correct that's true yes
they're like look we're over here trying
to worship Malik and you know create a
One World Currency and this guy Ian
cross is making these videos about
abolishing the Federal Reserve that's a
problem for us
at the end but it's it set it on the
Georgia Guidestones they want to reduce
the population
it said maintain a population under 500
million
it didn't say reduce oh I see what
you're saying yes but there's a reason
why they want a small population because
they just want the elites and then
basically like a housekeeping staff so
they're just the ones there to be like
two classes and there's that's kind of
where we're going there is no middle
class anymore and that's why I think
people have lost the American dream
because nobody can afford a single
family home and if you look at like the
price of a single family home in the 60s
to now I mean it's just it's impossible
our parents had
a lot easier when it comes to I came to
the American dream the US government and
big Pharma and tech companies love
depressed people because who's going to
get into these pods like if you have
friends a community and a family why
would you be like I need to live in
virtual reality whereas if you don't
like your life you're lonely or
depressed of course you would get into
the Pod you're the first to go but they
like everyone here
they don't like liberals I maintain this
position
what do you mean
that
when we're talking about powerful
wealthy Elites and people who run
corporations yeah if you went to the
average CEO and said which group of
people would you rather have rural
conservatives or Urban liberals they'd
say rural conservatives hands down
unquestionably
you think that I I would say it is
fairly obvious for a lot of reasons the
first
think about climate change big problems
but it's all stemming from cities think
about all the problems Democrats talk
about with overpopulated prisons cities
then think about the fact that
conservatives don't protest but they
don't say that they're killing cows in
Ireland sure sure it's not absolute but
what I'm saying is conservatives don't
protest they live on Little Farms and
mind their own business the amount of
pollution produced by the average
conservative is substantially lower than
produced by the average liberal so if
you look at everything these Global
leads are talking about all the problems
they're experiencing it is dense cities
not rural populations so I always put I
always put it like this if Alex if a
person come up to you and said Alex have
you considered aborting your children
what would you like do you think that
person's your friend or do you think
they hate you
how would you consider sterilizing your
kid just just wondering like come on
yeah I think you're a psycho I mean
that's not a person who likes you yes so
when you have these Democrat politicians
and people like Bill Gates or whatever
being like I think people should be
allowed to remove their children and
abortion should be available for all of
these people it's like I kind of think
you hate them and you're trying to have
less of them you know what I mean yeah
but to be fair did you see that Lindsey
Graham where he was talking to zelinski
and how he was so happy about more dead
Russians
that means more dead Russians good so
he's I guess conservative but it doesn't
matter the right side or the left side
They Don't Care About Us they don't care
about their this is my point this is my
point the way I describe it is you've
got a chicken coop the chickens keep
pooping in their water you go into the
chicken coop and you say Hey you
chickens you stop pooping in your water
the next day you come outside half the
chickens are still pooping in the water
the other half have stopped which
chickens do you eat yeah the water
pooping ones the ones that won't listen
that keep polluting and destroying
everything so when I look at when you go
to West Virginia and you drive around
what do you find people have solar
panels people have septic systems which
are very self-regular regulating in a
lot of ways you've got to get them
pumped but if done right it could be you
don't you might not have to so
the pollution produced in rural areas
dissipates in cities it concentrates and
then what do you see the advocacy for in
blue States things that
stop liberals from having kids so it may
be they really don't care about us at
all and all they're saying is let's
enact policies that result in less
people but those policies
disproportionately reduce liberal
populations yes yes but I also see a
disdain from the Elites for people who
are self-sufficient and they continue to
pass legislation that is contrary to
people being self-sufficient there's a
huge just for you know you can't even
collect rain water for God's sake in
many states
there's there's
not blue cities those are around like
West like you look at Red States and
they're doing the opposite of that no
even in red States there's still a lot
of restrictions to our restrictions that
I don't agree with I think they have a
dis we are winning a lot of flyover
states and the people there I think they
do have it to stay informed we have
absolutely one on two way the expansion
of constitutional carry is unprecedented
the expansion of shell issue in recent
years yeah yeah I mean the past 30 years
you know in the 80s you couldn't get
guns and it wasn't until 2008 the
Supreme Court I think it was Heller it
was a Heller versus DC when they were
like actually it is an individual right
to keeping bear arms you know outside of
your home and stuff like that so
we're winning on that all that in New
York you struggle in in blue dense blue
areas life is a struggle they're
releasing criminals into the cities
there's an increase in violent crime
people are getting pushed in front of
trains you come out to West Virginia you
got no problems crime is down it's lower
than the national average I haven't seen
one crackhead since I've been here from
New York and they do have drug problems
in West Virginia you know they do have
opiate problems but I didn't know this I
actually thought crime was was fairly
bad here and then uh we had I think was
Riley Moore talking about it I pulled up
the stats below average crime in West
Virginia Statewide and all jurisdictions
is below average so if you want to live
in New York where they're releasing
criminals and justifying it where
they're allowing lewd and lascivious
performances advocating for people to
terminate their kids or sterilize their
kids those things all result in the
destruction of that population meanwhile
in red States they're doing things that
allow the individual to thrive and and
to flourish so they can't even have
pizza why oh I know right why is this
agenda is it agenda 2030 they're trying
to create like Mega Forest they're
trying to like
re-naturalize a large segments of Earth
and not have humans go there like no
more human Footprints in these big
forested areas they want people away
from like the out the
whatever you would call this the the
rural areas and they want to pack people
into these mega cities I don't know if
I'm not speaking for everybody but yeah
but but a 15-minute city is not it's not
a mega City it's a small pod City yeah
where everything's 15 minutes away yeah
where everyone's like hospital every
your grocery store everything you would
need a 15-minute city is not going to be
20 million people in one circular City
it's going to be small pod cities all
over the place
um the reason why that's bad too is it's
easier to shut down when it's a small
City well exactly yeah well I don't
trust these people at all anyway so it
doesn't really matter what to wrap it
all up with a nice little bow who they
like and don't like they do bad things
dude Rural Life is nice I'm really
starting to love it well you know it's
funny because everybody talks about
Texas I remember Ian you were just like
oh you know Texas and Joe Rogan people
were moving there and the reason why
Texas is good is because it's for fat
people there's like a CVS in every
corner there's a McDonald's and so it's
like yeah I love the real life too but I
kind of like that I can just like go to
the Walmart or buy my tug friendly
bathing suit at Target and my Big Mac
okay all within half a mile thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time